[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend Norbert König ist auch dabei
für den Sport guten Abend schauen wir
auf die Nachrichten Themen von heute
ein Wahlsieger der Brüssel und Kiew
Sorgen macht Robert fizow gewinnt die
Parlamentswahl in der Slowakei mit
seiner links-nationalen und
prorussischen Partei
auch Polen steht vor einer Richtungswahl
Oppositionschef TuS ruft seine Anhänger
auf die Straße hunderttausende kommen
und es war ein kalter Sommer mit
ungewöhnlich viel Schnee in der Arktis
dadurch ist diesmal weniger
eisgeschmolzen als früher sagen die
Wissenschaftler von der Polarstern
bislang unterstützte die Slowakei ihre
ukrainischen Nachbarn und den Kurs der
EU doch das könnte sich ändern ihr
werdet keine einzige Patrone mehr in die
Ukraine schicken wenn er die Wahl
Gewinne das hatte der Pro russische
frühere Ministerpräsident Vieh zu
angekündigt jetzt hat er überraschend
hoch gewonnen seine links-nationale
Partei ist mehr wurde mit rund 23%
stärkste Kraft deutlich dahinter mit 18
Prozent die Pro westliche Partei
progressives Slowakei von Michael
schimetzka entscheidend für die
Regierungsbildung könnte die
linksgerichtete Klass und Peter
Pellegrini werden mit 15 Prozent aus
Bratislava Britta Hilpert
entschuldigen Sie meine Stimme sagt
Robert fizo wir haben gestern lang
gefeiert
er hat es gestern Abend wohl zunächst
selbst kaum vermutet dass er so klar
gewinnen würde robert vizo hat sich
durchgesetzt er wird nach drei Jahren
Opposition nun wohl zum vierten Mal
Ministerpräsident erwartet nur auf der
Startsignal
wir warten jetzt auf den Anruf der
Präsidentin sie gibt den Auftrag zur
Regierungsbildung davor sehe ich keine
Notwendigkeit Gespräche zu führen
wieso kann nur in einer Koalition
regieren mit zwei Parteien am
wahrscheinlichsten gelingt ihm das mit
der Partei von Peter peligrini der
früher selbst den Vizes mehr war und den
Nationalisten
dem liberalen schimetzka gelang als
zweiten ein Achtungserfolg aber sein
Hauptziel viel zu verhindern verfielter
wohl
wir wissen alle was eine Vize Regierung
bedeutet für unser Rechtssystem den
Rechtsstaat und die politische
Orientierung die Wahl stand unter
starken Einfluss pro russischer
Propaganda viel Zugriff das auf
versprach statt für die Ukraine mehr
Geld für Slowaken auszugeben das brachte
ihm viele Stimmen ein Slowakei Fürst das
heißt für viel zu keine weiteren
Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine und
Russland Sanktionen ja auch nicht sollte
es viel zu gelingen eine Regierung zu
bilden wird es noch schwieriger für EU
und NATO Einigkeit zu finden
in Bratislava beginnt wohl eine neue Ära
für die Slowakei und ein wenig auch für
die EU
in der türkischen Hauptstadt Ankara hat
es am Morgen einen Bombenanschlag
gegeben mittlerweile hat sich die
kurdische Terrororganisation PKK dazu
bekannt nach Angaben des Innenministers
sprengte sich ein Attentäter in der Nähe
des Parlaments in die Luft ein weiterer
sei beim Schusswechsel mit der Polizei
getötet worden zwei Beamte wurden leicht
verletzt das Zentrum war weiträumig
abgesperrt das Parlament tagte trotzdem
zum ersten Mal nach der Sommerpause
der Deutsche Städtetag waren vor einem
aus des deutschlandtickets grund sei
dass es von Bund und Ländern noch keine
finanziellen Garantien gäbe
Hauptgeschäftsführer die die sagte den
Funke Medien es sei inakzeptabel das
Verkehrsminister Wissing weitere
Gespräche mit den Ländern ablehne bisher
ist ungeklärt wer im kommenden Jahr die
mehr Kosten für das günstige Ticket
finanziert
in zwei Wochen entscheiden die Polen bei
der Parlamentswahl wie es politisch mit
ihrem Land weitergeht
hunderttausende Menschen demonstrierten
heute für einen Wechsel gegen die
nationalkonservative Regierungspartei
peace zum sogenannten Marsch der eine
Million Herzen aufgerufen hatte die
liberale bürgerliche
Opposition sie warnt vor einem Ruck noch
weiter nach rechts aus Warschau Natalie
Steger
viele sind eigens nach Warschau gereist
sowie Pauline aus Danzig sie alle eint
sie wollen die nationalkonservative
Regierung nach acht Jahren nicht mehr an
der Macht sie meine Kinder sollen in
einem demokratischen Land leben auf das
ich stolz bin als Europäerin offen für
andere Menschen
wenn wir uns nicht motivieren dann
werden wir in einem Land Aufwachen dass
uns unsere Rechte beraubt
aufgerufen zu dem Marsch hat Polens
liberal konservativer Oppositionsführer
Tusk sein Kurs klar pro europäisch er
will Warschaus angespanntes Verhältnis
zu Brüssel wieder verbessern
das Unmögliche ist möglich geworden wenn
ich dieses Mehr von Herzen sehe dann
spüre ich sehr wohl dass dieser Wende
Moment in der Geschichte unseres
Heimatlandes kommt
Historie
will sich als Versöhner zeigen Polens
Gesellschaft ist gespalten seitdem die
Regierung Frauenrechte beschnitten hat
Kontrolle über Medien und Gerichte
ausgebaut hat die peace kämpft mit
harten Bandagen hier im Partei Spot wird
regelmäßig als ewiger Handlanger Berlins
dargestellt als Verräter seines Landes
in den Umfragen liegt die
Regierungspartei peace vorne die
Hoffnung der Opposition heute das von
hier aus der Funke überspringt und noch
unentschlossene Wähler für sie stimmen
werden denn die peace bräuchte bei einem
Sieg wohl einen Koalitionspartner und
das könnten die Ultra rechten sein es
ist eine Richtung Wahl für Polen
in Spanien sind bei einem Brand in einem
Vergnügungsviertel mindestens 13
Menschen ums Leben gekommen mindestens
vier wurden verletzt das Feuer war in
einer Diskothek in Murcia in Südosten
des Landes gegen 6 Uhr morgens
ausgebrochen die Flammen breiteten sich
auf zwei benachbarte Clubs aus und
konnten erst nach drei Stunden gelöscht
werden danach suchten Rettungskräfte den
Tag über Nacht vermissten die Brand
Ursache ist noch unklar
die Polarstern auf diesem Schiff waren
50 Forscherinnen und Forscher zwei
Monate lang in der Arktis um zu
untersuchen wie sich der Klimawandel auf
das Meer Eis auswirkt nach ihrer
Rückkehr in Bremerhaven zog die kubilanz
die Eisschmelze lege eine
Verschnaufpause ein das sei aber kein
Grund zum Aufatmen Katharina Weisgerber
umfangreich ist die wissenschaftliche
Ausbeute der polarstern-expedition und
bereits vor Auswertung ist klar die
Veränderungen in der Arktis sind
dramatisch
das Eis war sehr flach Schnee bedeckt es
war von unten stark abgeschmolzen und
für mich als Meeresbiologin konnte ich
eben feststellen sein typisches leben
die eisalten viele der Lebewesen die das
Eis besiedeln die waren gar nicht
vorhanden das Forscherteam aus 15
Nationen darunter mehr als Physiker
Geologen und Chemiker begann seine
Expedition unter besonderen Vorzeichen
Hitzewellen im Atlantik der heißeste
globale Sommer aller Zeiten trotzdem
hatte ein Wetterphänomen die Eisfläche
vor einem neuen Rekordverlust geschützt
eine Folge von Tiefdruckgebieten
verhinderte das Driften der Eisschollen
nach Westen in wärmeres Wasser außerdem
lag ungewöhnlich viel Schnee das nun ein
Jahr mal mehr oder weniger mehr als hat
weil das Wetter oder die Winde anders
laufen kann uns nicht beruhigen
denn das mehr als wird kontinuierlich
weniger verliert rund 13 Prozent
innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts die
Veränderung sind schneller als im
anderen Regionen und gleichzeitig wissen
wir so wenig über die arktische Region
müssen aber verstehen als Menschen das
ist unsere Wetterküche sie ist nicht ein
weit ferner Ort sondern sie betrifft uns
alle nun werden die Daten der letzten
drei Expeditionen verglichen um den
Klimawandel in der Arktis besser zu
verstehen
jetzt bist du dran ja mit einem
Top-Ergebnis für eine Reiterin und drei
Reiter aus Deutschland und natürlich
auch für die vier Pferde die Springsport
ekip gewinnt das Finale des
traditionsreichen Nationenpreises in
Barcelona eine Genugtuung nach der knapp
verpassten EM-Medaille vor vier Wochen
als auch der letzte deutsche Starter
Richard Vogel auf United Touch
fehlerfrei bleibt ist klar die Deutschen
sind nicht mehr zu schlagen und beenden
die bislang enttäuschende Saison mit
einem Sieg vor Frankreich und Belgien
vorausgegangen war ein spannendes Finale
das sowohl Christian Kuckuck mit Checker
übrigens in Bestzeit als auch
Hans-Dieter Dreher auf Elysium trotz
Schrecksekunde mit null Fehlerpunkten
absolvierten zum ersten Mal nach 2016
gewinnt Deutschland wieder ohne
Strafpunkt für Bundestrainer Otto Becker
eine ganz spezielle Leistung
der VfL Wolfsburg DFB-Pokalsieger der
Frauen hat auch sein zweites Saisonspiel
in der Bundesliga gewonnen 4:2 bei
Eintracht Frankfurt nach zweimaligem
Rückstand und einem hervorragenden
Hackentrick von Alexandra Popp setzt
die polnische Nationalspielerin vor
13.500 Fans den Schlusspunkt Wolfsburg
jetzt kommt gleich mit Spitzenreiter
Hoffenheim auf Platz 2
ebenfalls 4 zu 2 allerdings für die
Gastgeber endet das erste Sonntagsspiel
der Männer Bundesliga Darmstadt 98
feiert gegen Werder Bremen den ersten
Saison Sieg und verlässt damit die
Abstiegsplätze
gesundheitlich angeschlagen erschöpft
und trotzdem erfolgreich Tennisprofi
Alexander Zverev setzt seine Siegesserie
im Einzelfahrt sein Achtelfinalspiel in
Peking gegen den Spanier Alejandro da
Vidovic fukina dauerte bis fast 3 Uhr
gestern Nacht nach drei aufreibenden
Sätzen und einem verlorenen Marathon
Doppel heute trifft es wäre morgen auf
den Helenen Nicolas Harry Pool
lauter schöne Namen im Tennis
hervorragend vielen Dank die
Temperaturen fühlen sich nicht wirklich
nach Oktober an morgen im Norden teils
dichte Wolken und im küstenumfeld etwas
Regen sonst sonnig und trocken
Höchstwerte zwischen 19 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 30 Grad am
Oberrhein
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers hier
übernimmt morgen nitri Sirenen wir sagen
danke und tschüss und empfehlen jetzt
Türkei und Berlin direkt